camila harris still has not commented on
the andrew cuomo scandal
and uh and that's you know an issue
because she had plenty to say of course
about
brett kavanaugh about donald trump's
sexual harassment accusers and so on
she was one of the big believe all women
people
and she hasn't said anything about the
sexual harassment claims against andrew
cuomo
jen uh pasaki was asked about that and
and here's what she said
vice president kamala harris is one of
the most vocal critics of justice brett
kavanaugh
of senator al franken when they faced
similar allegations
she said repeatedly i believe them
the women but she hasn't said anything
about the three women who are accusing
governor andrew cuomo and now this
third accuser anna roosh she actually
worked
for the biden harris campaign so at what
point
is the first female vice president going
to say something about this
well i i know that's how the the vice
president continues to feel and
uh the benefit of doing a briefing every
day is that i can certainly speak on
behalf of the president and the vice
president and so let me reiterate that
they both believe that every woman
coming forward should be heard
should be treated with dignity and
treated with respect
as you all know the new york attorney
general will oversee an independent
investigation
with subpoena power and the governor's
office said he will fully cooperate and
we certainly
support that moving forward but as you
know it's one thing to hear it
from you and it's appreciated but it's
another thing to hear it
from the vice president or the president
himself can we expect to hear
from either of them on this topic
anytime soon well again i'm speaking on
their behalf that's how they feel
uh they're personally both view this as
a a
situation where uh bo all of the women
coming forward
should be treated with dignity and
respect and should have their voices
heard
uh and that's uh the representation of
their points of view
okay sure now we have to we have to
clarify you know to stipulate
that uh that that of course uh every
time this comes up we have to say that
this is not the real andrew cuomo
scandal uh this is not even the real
engine
the android cuomo scandal that we
primarily need to hear camille harris
talking about
um or or condemning the real scandal
is are the policies that he put in place
that led to the
deaths of thousands of elderly people in
his state that's the real scandal
not the fact that he you know touched a
woman's cheek and flirted with some
women
on the job that's inappropriate behavior
uh
as opposed to killing lots of people so
not the real scandal but as far as that
goes you notice this shift
pretty obvious it's not a very nuanced
shift so i'm sure anyone can notice it
but you notice the shift that the
democrats do
now because originally she said she said
well
we believe that all women should be
treated with dignity and respect
and they should be heard so any woman
who has an accusation we should treat
them with respect and they should be
heard
that's what she says now which obviously
yeah we all agree
we can all agree in principle in theory
treat people with respect
if someone has a claim and accusation
we'll hear it let's let's listen
but that's not what they said in the
past what they said in the past was
believe all women there is a big
difference
i'm sure you could probably spot between
hear all women
and believe all women pretty big
difference
and so they're they're making that that
little
subtle adjustment and hoping we don't
notice well it's basically the same
thing
no it's not at all because our point
all along and when i say our i mean the
rational people
um and increasingly that is really the
real dividing line in american culture
now it's irrational people versus
irrational people
but our point all along was yeah we'll
hear everybody
uh we'll hear her you know if someone
has a claim we'll listen to you
what is it but we're not gonna believe
it
simply because we heard it the believing
part requires
reasons evidence
that's that's where that comes in listen
hit that subscribe button right now do
it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated